[音楽]
先月の話の2部として 今日お話しさせていただきます
先月はごく普通の一般的に
知識っていうのは どういうふうに獲得できますかという
そんなに仏教だけの話ではなくて
普通にこの心の話だったと思います
どのように我々人間が 知識を獲得するべきかという
いろいろな勉強方法とか
いろいろなものを記憶する方法とか
そこら辺を いくらかは話しました
その話も途中で
時間が なくなって終わりました
全部 話したわけではないんです
今日はそこをそれで終わってしまって
智慧という
知識と智慧というテーマですから
今日は 智慧の話をしてみましょう
どう違いますか? 知識と智慧は
どう違いますかね？
言葉に操られないで 新しく考えないと
理解できないかもしれません
一応 私は自分なりに
定義をいたしますが
知識っていうのは勉強と同じもので
言葉の世界なんですね
概念の世界
頭の中でいろんな概念を
言葉として詰め込む
それは知識というんですね
そういうものによって
我々は元気に生きてるんですね
知識があるんだから生きてると
我々は子供たちを学校に行かせて
何をして欲しいかというと
知識を思う存分 頭の中に
いっぱい詰めて欲しいんですね
性格は気にしない
性格はどうでもいいんです
知識さえあれば
ということで
教育は完全に
現代教育っていうのは知識の世界
いわゆる頭の中にいろいろな概念
いろいろな言葉
言葉はたくさんないんですけど
いろいろな言葉をあっちこっち
回したりして振り回したりして
いろいろと頭に詰め込んであげる
それから それはいろいろな試験
とか面接とかそういうところで
どれぐらい知識が
固まっているかどうかを調べて
この人はいいな
この人はいいなと
入学させたり
会社に入社させたりする
まあ そこまではいいんだけど
せっかく入学したんだけど
ろくな学生生活が
できない人もいるし
入社はしたんだけど
会社のためには
何の役にも立たない
ただ生ゴミだけの
人間もいるんですね
まあ生きてる
それで困ったなとか
ああだこうだと
また知識を詰め込もうと
思っちゃうんですね
それどう違いますかと
同じ学校を出ても
同じ教育を受けても
それぞれ人間
違うところはあるんですね
ある人は役に立つし
ある人は全く役に立たない
そこら辺から智慧の
世界が始まるんです
知識が言葉の集まりであるならば
そこに論理というものがありますね
その論理も正しい論理じゃなくて
人間の勝手な論理なんです
ですから
世の中にある 倫理 論理というのは
そんな大したことないんです
全部好き勝手に いい加減なものしかないんです
ある時期は これはやってはいけない
あれはやってはいけないと
ものすごく言って
大変 怒られたりするし
ちょっと
5年、6年経つと
まあそんなことはどうでもいいやと
違うことをやってはいけないと
言ったりするし
それに 何の根拠も 何も ないんですね
例えば 論理にしても
今日 ちょっと
頭に浮かんだことなんですが
中国の指導者が
死んじゃって
死んじゃって と言ったら
失礼かどうか分かりませんけど
亡くなりまして
それについて いろいろ番組があって
そこで日本側の 考え方出ていますけど
計画的な経済システムを解放して
自由経済を導入した人だから
大変素晴らしいことをした人ですよと
それだけ褒めてるんですね
いわゆる 他の人々に商売を
できるようにしてくれたんだから
素晴らしい人だと
その人にはそれしか 徳がないみたいなんですね
だから すごく賢そうに喋るんだけど
ただ 自分勝手に 喋ってるだけではないかと
私が その時
これなんです 感じたのは
自由経済ということは
その自由経済の国々は
すごくありがたい
それこそ真実だと言うんだけど
その国の経済状態が自由になって
一番 悪知恵がある人々は 思う存分儲かってください
弱い者は死んでしまえ というシステムでしょう
その いいところだけを見て
悪いところは全く無視・無関心で
経済学や論理を喋ってるんですね
それはその人々にとってはすごい
正しい知識的な話なんですけど
どんな経済にも興味ない人が
第三者の立場で見ると
なんかちょっとおかしいんですね
じゃあ中国のリーダーが 中国の問題を 全部解決したんですか？というと
それは全くなくて
市場経済状態が出てきたんだから
かなり中国では
社会状態が崩れちゃって
いろいろ問題がありまして
とんでもない金持ちが出てきて
ご飯も食べられないほど ものすごく
貧しい人々が出てきたりとか
それでも政府にはもう
お金がないんだから
どうしようもなくて
あんた方は勝手にしなさい
という感じになっちゃって
生きるか死ぬかぐらいの きつい状態で生きている 中国地方もあるんです
そこでマフィアみたいに
暴力団が出てくるは
日本にありとあらゆる 密航組織が出てくるは
問題だらけなんですね
前はそれほどなかったんだけど
ですから
人間というのは 勝手に 市場経済こそありがたいと 言うんだけど
そうじゃなくて そちらにも いいところも悪いところもあります
その両方を考えて喋るならば
いくらかの合理なんですけど
そうでは絶対ないんです
世の中では
自分が好きなものは
万々歳と応援するだけで
嫌いなものはもう
絶対的に嫌い 嫌い 嫌
悪人だと決めてるだけで
そういう世界で人間
ずっと生きているんだから
そういう理論なんですけど
やっぱり 我々の 知識の世界というのは そういう世界なんですね
例えば医者に聞けば
風邪ひいて来ました
じゃあ手術しましょうと
風邪でも できれば 手術したいんですね 医者が
それに 何か文句言ったら
あんた方は 何を知ってるんですかと
冗談じゃないと
また怒られるんですね
がんになったら 自分で決めます
それは患者さんに決められませんよ
医者が決めるもんだと
偉そうなことを
言ったりするんですね
やっぱり自分勝手なんですね
この知識の世界っていうのは
ちゃんと具体的に物事を見て
バランスを取って
判断しようとはしない
医者は 医者の勝手で判断する
弁護士は 弁護士の勝手で その角度で物事を判断する
政治家は自分勝手で
両側の立場 いろんな多側面から 物事を見ようとはしない
ですから知識っていうのは
みんないっぺんにありがたい ありがたい ありがたいと思う
そんなに一言では
言えるもんじゃないんです
じゃあ 知識はいけませんか？
それも言えますと
とんでもない話で
ですから
知識の世界はそういう世界で
まず言葉の世界
概念の世界で
それから論理
一つのロジック世界なんですけど
僕ら仏教からはそれは
pseudo-logicというんですね
見せかけのロジックだと
全然 論理じゃないんです
仏教から見れば
論理は 全く 成り立ってないんだけど
でも一般の方々にとっては
自分たちは しっかりした 合理的な人間だと
そういう風に思って 生きているんですね
例えば 長生きしなくちゃとかね
今日 ある人が電話かけてきて
「何一つも希望通りに
いかないんですよ この頃」と言って
ものすごい腹が立ってるんですね
私も腹が立ったんですね
全部自分の希望通りに
行ってほしいと思う
バカも いいバカもんなんですね
それぐらい 屁理屈なんですね
ちょっと考えてみてください
私たちの希望通りに
世の中が動いちゃったら
1週間で終わりですよ
この地球も全部
それぐらい人間というのは
汚くて恐ろしくて
あいつは憎いと思っちゃったら
すぐその人をやっつけて
殺してしまいたいでしょうに
あれ欲しいと思ったら
欲しいものはすぐ
自分のものにしたいでしょう
お金があったらって
お金が いくらあっても キリがないでしょうに
それで 欲しい 欲しいと思ったある人が
すごい金持ちになると思っちゃって
世界中のお金を その人のところに 集めちゃったら
どうなるんですかね？世界は
こんなに 恐ろしい世界なのに たった一つ 救いがあるのは
何一つも 人間の希望通りに いかないことなんです
もし間違ってでも 人間の希望通りにいったならば
大変なことになるんです
そこを合理的に考えない
自分の心に聞かない
私の希望って何ですか？と
そこで 私の希望通りに 何でもかんでもいってくださいと
頼んでみたら
恐ろしくてしょうがないんですね
ですから
世の中っていうのは 希望通りにいかないのは当たり前で
それが嫌というのは合理的ですか？
希望通りにいかないのは嫌ですよと
私は元気で頑張って
物事を自分の希望通りにしますと
その人々は すごい元気だと言う
よく頑張る人だと言う
ちゃんとした合理的な人間だと言う
世界は言うんだけど
でもあれは合理的ですかね？
物事は 自分の希望どおりに いくんですかね？
いかないでしょう
何一つも
それなのに
そう言ってほしい
人は死にたくないでしょう
希望どおりに言えば
死ななかったらどうなるんですかね?
もし昔の人々が希望どおりにいって
死ななかったならば
我々今ここにいないでしょうに
なんか蜂の巣の蜂のように
いっぱい 人、人、人だけいるんであって
そこで生活できないでしょう⁉
蜂にもものすごい広大な
領域が必要なんですよ
蜂蜜を採るために
花から 蜜を吸うために
人間よりものすごい
土地が必要なんですよ
小さな蜂に
それで人間死ななかったら
どうなるんですかね?
年とっても死なないと
例えば 電車に飛び込んでも
むちゃくちゃに
ぺっちゃんこになっても
それでも死なないんだと
面白いですか?
それでも死にたくないと
年は取りたくないんだと
よく言うもんですね
それで薬も作る
不老長寿とかね
長生きできるようにとか
人間の健康を守るためにとかね
じゃあ見てください
ずっと科学的に
研究して 研究しても
医者であろうが
誰も知らないほどの薬の種類が あるでしょう
じゃあ何か助かったこと
一つでもありますかね
結局 人間は昔も同じく 病気になるのであって
お医者さんはいつでも
お手上げ状態で
人がなんとか 縁がいい
なんかラッキーで
病気が治った方が治るか
あるいは そうでなくなって死ぬか
どっちかなんですね
結局 いまだに我々は薬を飲んで
健康的に
なるかならないかっていうのは
体の勝手であって
科学のおかげではないんですね
どんな素晴らしい薬であろうが
体がそれを否定しちゃったら
何の意味もないし
そういうふうな世界で
論理はあるんだけど
論理は なんか ものすごくいい加減で
ちょっと考えたらおかしいんですね
ですから
僕らの話も聞いて
なんかこの人の話でも聞いて
自分の希望どおりに物事が
いってくれるんじゃないかなとかね
長生きできるんじゃないかなと
病気治してくれるんじゃないかなと
思ったりして仏教を聞くんだけど
そういう約束をしてね
人を騙すことは
いとも簡単にできますけどね
でも事実は逆なんですね
そうなっちゃったらものすごい
地獄そのものになるんですね
希望どおりに物事がいったら
それはそれで置いておいて
論理の世界
言葉の世界は知識の世界
それから知識っていうのは
物事の一部だけを勉強する
物事を 全部勉強しようとしないのは 知識の世界なんです
何か一つ知って
それで食べているんですね
全てを知っちゃったら困るんです
知識の世界では
医者は患者さんのことを
機械みたいに扱って
いらないものを切って捨てて
抜いて なんとかして
はい　終わりましたと
そこで患者が治ろうが
それから
どんなひどい目に合おうが
それは別にお医者さんの
仕事ではないんですね
一応 癌だから
癌を取り出しましたと
それからどうやって
生きていくんですか？と
それは知らないんだ
そんなことは
胃も腸も全部取り出しましたと
そしたら もう食べられないでしょう
それだったら
何か管でも入れて栄養をあげますと
それで栄養あげたところで
何か体の他のところが
おかしくなったら
それだったら
そこら辺またいじりますと
そういうふうなことで
これで人間ですか？とか
ここまでして
生きていきたいんですか？とか
例えば 腸も捨てて 胃も捨てて
肺も なんでもかんでも捨てて
ただ なんとかベッドの上の
肉の塊になってでも
長生きするべきですか？とかね
そこら辺をお医者さんは 考えてはいけないことで
考えないことで
知識っていうのはそういうもので
考えちゃったら仕事が
できなくなっちゃうんですね
お医者さんにも
足を切断しなくちゃいけなくなったら
何のことなく平気で
足を切断して捨てると
これから人生どうなる？
それは別に気にしない
だからといってお医者さんに
悪口を言うことはできないし
なぜならそれ知識の世界だから
自分の分野しかもう考えません
弁護士も同じでしょう
どんな犯罪者であろうが
弁護士は弁護するでしょう
そこで上手な弁護士だったら
その人を無罪にすることですよ 結局は
自分が弁護する人々が みんな有罪になるんだったら
いい弁護士には なりっこないんだから
あの弁護士に頼んだら
お金も高いだけではなくて
必ず裁判に負けるんだというならば
もう弁護士じゃないでしょう
ですから
弁護士の仕事っていうのは
犯罪者を
逃がしてあげることなんです
そこを真面目に考えちゃったら
弁護士には なりっこなくなっちゃうんですね
だからとんでもない犯罪者と同じ
悪いことをするのは
弁護士の仕事だから
もっと悪いのは法律で
守られてるんだから弁護士が
そこまで考えちゃったら
弁護士になれないんです
ですから
まあとにかく弁護しますと
人々を助けてあげますと
いわゆるいろいろ 裁判抱えたりして
いろいろなことで悩んで
まあ どうしようもない
法律はわかりませんから
ですから
私は法律の専門家になって
そういう法律の助けを必要な人々を
助けてあげますというふうに
自分に言い返しちゃって
世の中にそういう法律という
lawyersという仕事があるんです
だから本当にあれで人を助けられて
いるかないかっていうのは
また別な話で
だからそこまで考える
必要はないんですね
知識の世界では
政治の世界は
政治家は自分がどうすれば
自分の権力を
野党側に奪われないかということ
だけ考えて行動するんです
もし政治家が国のために
国民のために行動したら
すぐその政府はもう倒れちゃうんです
それはもう歴史的な事実なんです
正直なものには政治できないんです
政治を取ったら
必死で権力を守ることに
必死で苦労しなくちゃいけない
それは昔から
この地球にある事実なんです
でも 一般の人々を
守るために政治をやっている
例えば 今風に言えば
消費税を５%にして
それで国民のために
国民の希望通りにやってるんだ
そうですけどね
また それを据え置きにするんだそうですね ５％を
それをすごいいいこと
してるように喋るんですね
大きなお世話です
３％の消費税を５％にして
それまた 来年は それ以上は上げないで 待ってるんだと
この 待ってることに
すごく威張ってるんだから
自分が５%にしたことには 何も言わないとか
そんな理屈ではできないんです
とにかく私が言う理屈では
政治も弁護士も何一つ
成り立たないんですね
もし私が言うことを 真面目に聞いちゃったら
もう何もできなくなっちゃうんです
政治もできなくなっちゃうし
医者の仕事もできなくなっちゃうし
私は 仏教の立場で言うんであって
社会の知識人の立場っていうのは
物事を 一つの側面でだけ見て行動しろと
それからどうなるか
それからどうなるかと
全部考えちゃうと
何もできなくなるんです
例えば タバコ会社作ったんだと
それだったら
どうすればいいんですか？
片っ端からタバコを
売るしかないでしょう
すごい 投費して
タバコ会社作ったならば
ありとあらゆる宣伝を
しなくちゃいけない
タバコはとても体に
いいことだよと言えません
だから全部宣伝に嘘を
言わなくちゃいけない
美しい風景とか
スイスの風景とか
大変魅力のある馬の写真とか
すごい美しい美人並んだりとかね
有名な人々を出したりとか
そこで「you will speak LURK」
と言うんですね
それ何を言ってるんですか？あの宣伝で
何も言ってないんです
でも そういう宣伝によって
タバコを買ったりする
もし タバコの会社の社長が
本当にタバコっていうのはこんな
売りまくっていいんですか？
これでがんになるんだから
自分でがんセンターでも
作ってやろうと 利益で
タバコを吸った人々が
がんになっちゃったら
私のがんセンターに来れば半額で
治療してあげましょうと言っちゃうと
よく考えると 親切な行為なんですけど
それだったら その会社のタバコは
誰も吸わないんです
ですから
そういうものには大反対する
お金も出せない
援助もしない
そういう会社は
できればスポーツとか
音楽系統とか芸術系統とか
そこら辺にいくらか
お金をあげたりする
そういう風になってるんですね
もしタバコ会社の社長が
真面目に合理的に考えちゃったら
もう仕事できなくなっちゃうんです
ですから
自分の立場だけを見て計算して
どんな俳優さんに
コマーシャルを頼めば売れるかと
どんな人が人気ありますかとかね
それは自分が買って
そういうふうにコマーシャルして
まあ とにかく売ると
それだけの世界なんですね
学者の世界も同じ
歴史学者は歴史ばっかり語っていて
他の学問とは
何の連絡もないんです
考古学者は穴掘るだけでも
現代人にとっては
別に何も役に立つことはしない
穴を掘って 穴を掘って
何かまあ
壺のかけらとか何か
見つかっちゃって
それまた 大体 1000年ぐらい
古いというふうな感じだったら
必ず 1500年か
2000年にするんです
聞いてみれば そうでないと
ロマンスがないんだと
それで僕らは偉い考古学者だと
褒めているんですね
やっぱりそれぐらいのことなんですね
僕は信じません
この 3000年のなんとかなんとか
2000年のなんとかなんとかと
全部信じないわけじゃないんだけど
きちんとした研究結果だったら
土のレイヤースありますから
そのレイヤースからちゃんと掘ってきて
このレイヤーは何年か
このレイヤーは何年かと
ちゃんとこのカーボン研究と
いろいろありますね
それから出てきた結果だったら
いくらかそうだろうと
でも ピッタリ日にち言うことは
できませんけど
でもたまに学者の間で
異論があるんですね
これは 1500年古い
ある人は
いえ  2300年古い
あるいは 3000年古いという場合は
みんな自分の
ロマンスを語っているだけなんです
とにかく
だからといって
考古学者の世界は
そういう何か壺の欠片とかね
何か古い人々のゴミ箱とかね そういうもを
縄文人にとってゴミ箱ですね 発見発掘しているのは
そこら辺から人の性格を
なんとか考えてみようとか
楽しく遊んでるんですね
それによって何か社会に
貢献するものとかね
だから現代生きてる我々の生活に
何か役に立った
ということはないんです
そこら辺まで考えちゃうと
あの仕事は
できなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから
もし仏教的な考え方が
入っちゃったら
とんでもないことになっちゃう
もう何一つ できなくなるんです
ですから
私が申し上げたいのは
この知識世界っていうのは
論理はあるんだけど
全部 完全たるすべてのものを把握して
できあがっている論理
ではないんです
その自分の分野を どう成立させるか ということしか考えない
弁護士の方々の やり方を 私は知ってますけど
例えば 誰かの
弁護をする場合は
自分たちの証人出しちゃうんですね
警察側からではなくて
「いいえ この人は無罪ですよ」
というために
たまに 反対の証人も
出す場合があるんですね
その時は たまに 証人作るんですね
これぐらい誰かが言ってくれれば
これオッケーだ というふうな
法律上ありますね
証人を作っちゃうんです
あんたはこういうふうに
こういうふうに答えなさいと
それから自分たちで検挙を
探したところで
本当に 自分が
弁護をしようとすると
本当に 犯人だと
自分で証拠が見つかっちゃう
でも自分が見つけた証拠は
警察は見つかってないんです
その場合は弁護士さんが
どうすると思います？
警察側にあげますか？
「こういう証拠がありますから
それを使ってちゃんと
あなた方は訴えてください
私は 被告人のために
弁護しますよ」
ということに ならないんです
あの証拠を全部隠すんです
たとえ弁護士であろうとも
証拠を隠すことも犯罪なんです
でも 隠す 確実に
そうやって 隠さなきゃ
自分の仕事できないでしょう
自分が 無罪ですよということを
言わなくちゃいけない
自分に 揃った証拠の中では
有罪というふうに言える証拠が
いっぱいあるならば
それは全部なんとか 表に出ないようにと
そういう世界で我々は
生きて食べてるんですね
ですから 仏教から見れば
みんな法に則って
食べてるわけじゃないんです
法を犯して生活してるんです
法っていうのは
この普遍的な
法則なんですね
だからいろいろ
不幸なこともありますよ
だから 競争もあるし
倒産もするし
まあ それはしょうがない
そこまでは 知識の世界
知識に文句言わなきゃ
智慧の世界は
わからなくなりますから
仏教にも知識の
世界がありまして
論理の世界があります
仏教の知識っていうのは
ほとんどごく普通の科学的な
知識はそのまま認めるし
論理の場合は
ちょっと違うんですね
理論作っても 使っても
いいんだけど
ただ 一方的に使うなと
できるだけ
人々・生命の幸福を
より多くの人々の
幸福にならないと
その知識は捨てなさいと
その論理も捨てろと
という立場で
いわゆる道徳論を
重ね合わせているんですね
論理が倫理と
一緒でなければいけません
倫理も論理も一つになってなければ
いけないんですね
例えば 人にお金をあげるのは いいことですか? と言ったら
一般の人はものすごく無責任で いいことでしょう 別に
と思っちゃうかもしれません
仏教はそういうふうに
無責任には言わないんです
もし その人が お金をもらって
自分も幸福になって
より大勢の人々の
幸福を作る人であるならば
それはいいことであって
その人お金もらって
それで何か鉄砲でも買っちゃって
麻薬でも買って
それを使うならば
あれは道徳ではなくて
犯罪行為ですと
単なるじゃあ人に
10万円あげることは
正しいことですか？
悪いことですか？と言えば
そういうふうに判断するんです
ある人に10万円あげるのは
大変いいことで
素晴らしいことであって
ある人に10万円あげたら
あなたは犯罪者ですよと
でも 人の行動は
結局自分が10万円あげちゃって
ロスしただけなんですけど
あげたんだからといって得と
いうわけじゃないんですね
ですから 仏教の論理は いつでも 倫理と一緒なんですね
普通の社会の論理は 倫理と関係ない
倫理っていうのは迷惑なんですね
学校でも 倫理っていうのは
誰も気にしない
教えたくはない
子供たちも勉強したくない 科目なんですね
すごい迷惑なんです
でも倫理なくなっちゃったら
誰にも生きていられないんです
全部一発でなくなっちゃうんです
我々は道徳を守るんだから
平和でいるんです
それでもみんな道徳っていうのは
面倒くさいんだと
法律を守ることも 面倒くさいんだと
だから なんとかしてごまかそう
ごまかそうと
会社っていうのは
もし 法律で厳しく
罰せられない場合は
そんなに社員に
給料は払いたくないんですよ
社員は残業してくれて
でも残業手当もらわないんだったら
すごくありがたがるんです
でもありがとうとは言わない
言っちゃったら束縛されるんだから
当たり前だという
その場合でも
それでも
残業手当をあげなくちゃいけない
なぜならば
法律で決まってるんだから
それは ありがたく
くれてるわけじゃないんです
嫌でくれてるんです
給料さえ
まあ大体
僕はきつく言うだけで
まあ どこでもやっぱり
法律・道徳っていうのは
生活する上では邪魔になっている
とみんな思ってるんです
正しく生きることは 邪魔ですよと
それが どれほど屁理屈かというと
もし 社会から道徳が消えちゃったら
そこでもう
社会システムは終了 終わり
ただの野蛮の世界
お互いに殺しあって 終わるんです
ですから
今 現代のこの発展
見せかけの発展も
全て 科学的な発展も
何であろうとも
人間がいくらかでも
道徳的に生きているんだから
あるんで
存在しているんであって
道徳が消えちゃったら終わりと
例えば アメリカの
いろんなあっちこっちあるように
殺されるか生きてうちに
帰れるかわからないんだと
思っちゃったら
どうやって生きてればいいんですかね
我々の人生は
蚊と同じくなっちゃうんですね
蚊は 仕事に出る場合は
奥さんに言うんだそうですね
「これから仕事に行きますよ」と
それもう面白い話で
別に血を吸うのはメスだけですけど
「もし パチンと音を聞いたら
諦めてください」と
そんな感じになるでしょ
私たちも
もし 人間が道徳守らなかったら
それなのに
みんな道徳だけは嫌なんですね
学校でも それは
あまり大事な科目じゃないんです
高校試験では それ全然聞かない
大学入学試験には
全く縁のない話なんですね
入社試験にも縁のない話なんでしょ
結局は
よくも 人間屁理屈
使うなと僕は思いますよ
あれこそ 大事なのに
どれくらい 人は正直かとか
どれぐらい 約束を守れる人か
どれぐらい 責任持てるものかと
そこ 一番大事なんです
ですから
ありとあらゆる工夫して
その人の
ethical frameworkという
道徳的に どんな精神的な
どんなふうに
人ができているんですかと
調べた方がいいのに
そこは もういらない
スポーツは
どれぐらいやったんですか？とか
そればっかり聞くんです
だからサッカーよくできるんだからって
コンピューターソフトウェア会社にね
就職しても
コンピューター足で蹴って
プログラム作るんですかね
やっぱりそういうものを
聞くんですね
だから私はそういう
とんでもない理屈で
もう何回も面接をダメになった
覚えがあるんです
いろんな面接に行って
そんなくだらない質問するんです
僕は「そんな質問を聞いて
あなた方は どうなるんですか」と
またかえって 質問したんですね
そしたら怒られて「私たちが面接
やってるんだから
あなたは 言うことに答えなさい」と
そうしたら「私はそれに答えますけど
なんでこんなくだらない
質問するんです？
私も疑問があるんです」と
「私はこういう仕事のために 面接を受けてるんだから
私が知ってる限りは その仕事を 私にできるんだから 出したんでしょう
私が知っている限りは
そんな質問なんか
そんな内容全く関係ないんだ」と
そこでもう知識的な
喧嘩になっちゃって
それで いろいろ話あったんだけど
結局私はパスと
全く資格のない人を 選んじゃったんです
選んでも仕事はできない
それから頼んで 私にお願いしますから来てくださいと
僕は偉そうに威張って行ったんです
その時も面接はあったんだけど 僕は30分遅れて行ったんです
まあ それはみんなに できることではなくて
私はどうでもいいっていう感じで いたんだからいいんですけど
皆様は そんな大胆なことを してはいけませんし
ほとんど頼まれて 仕事した
若い時はね
世の中に ほとんどいないと思いますよ
年取ったところで 仕事を頼まれる場合はありますけど
経験を買いますからね
それは置いておいて
大体この道徳っていうのは 大変大事なものなんですけど
世俗的な世界では
それは無視しよう
無視しよう
無視しようと 思ってる
仏教の知識の世界で
違うところは
論理より倫理は先と
倫理は土台であって
そこに論理が成り立つんだと
こう言うんですね
知識は生き方によって
完成されるんだと
いわゆる知識と道徳といえば
知識の完成は道徳にあって
道徳の完成は知識にあるんだと
それ一つも
かけ離すことはできません
人間として
これ面白いストーリーで
あるバラモン人の若い人が
お釈迦様に会いに行ったんです
バラモンの文化では
バラモン人というのは
すごい偉いんです
バラモンの家族で生まれたら
生まれつき聖職者で
神の子で
もう他の人々には
どうすることもできない
人は生まれるとそういう家族で
生まれなくちゃいけない
他のところで生まれちゃったら
もう神の子ではないんです
ですから
自分たちは神様の子供 ということで威張ってるんですね
そこでこの人は バラモン人であると
バラモンっていうのは
いわゆる修行者という 意味もあって
知識人という意味もありまして
聖者という意味もあるんですね
全部自分のものだと 思ってるんですね
父親がバラモン人だったら
自分がもう聖者なんです
それだけのことで
まあ
それは仏教で認めてないんだけど
その子に聞いたんですね
「人が完全なバラモンに なるためには
どれぐらい条件必要ですか」と言ったら
彼がこう言うんですね
美しい 麗しい体格と体で
いわゆるかっこいいこと
きちんと見たらすごい人だと見える
もう一つは 7 代目まで
血統 ちゃんとバラモン系統の 血統がきちんとあること
3番目は ヴェーダ聖典や 注釈や歴史など
いろいろなものを覚えて 勉強していること
物事について ちゃんと判断できる
智慧があること それは5番目
4番目に言ったのは
道徳的にいい行いを
正しい生活を
悪いことをしないで
自分の口も体も守って生活すること
4番目には よく物事を理解できる 智慧があること
お釈迦様は「よしわかりました
この 5つは必要ですよ」と
「その 5つの中から１つぐらい 取り消すことはできますか」と
「例えばこの条件がなくてもOK だと
言えるものはありますか？」
と言ったら
あなたにできますかと考えること
この人は「できますよ」
「かっこいい人で生まれると
人の格好って別に関係ないんです」と
すごい いい美男でなければという
そんなこと関係ないんだ
ですからそれはカットできますと
この 4つの条件揃っていれば ぴったししたバラモンですと
お釈迦様はわかりました
すごいと
じゃあこの今
4つだけあればいいでしょ
この 4つから
何か一つ条件なくても いいという条件がないんですか？
と言ったら
ありますね
考えれば
この 7代まで血統は純血でなければ
そんなこと
どうでもいいんじゃないかと
誰が知ってるんですかと
ですからこの血統っていうのは 意味がないんだと
それ捨てられるんだと
また 2つ抜けちゃったんですね
次にもう一つ何か抜け落ちたら 何かないんですか？
と言ったら
こんないろんなことをね
ヴェーダやら歴史やら
あんなことを勉強しなくちゃ いけないと言っても
みんなにできるわけでもないし
あれもあんまり 役に立たないんですねと
それで捨てられます
結局 2つしか残らなかったんです
5つの条件で
お釈迦様は 最後に聞くんですね
この 2つの条件で何かなくても いいという何かないんですか？と
そしたら この若者は
これはちょっと無理ですと
智慧がないともうダメですと
人間には智慧があっても
道徳なければ何の意味もないんだと
ですから
道徳的な生き方と智慧の中で 一つ取れと言っても
それだけは取れませんと
家柄はどうであろうと
それにも関係なく
お釈迦様はまさにあなたの 言う通りですよ
sīla-paridhotānaṃ paññā,
paññā-paridhotānaṃ sīlaṃ.　という
彼の言葉をお釈迦様は
褒めてあげたんですね
wisdom perfects morality,
morality perfects wisdom.という
道徳的な生き方によって 智慧が清らかになると
智慧によって道徳的な 生き方が清らかになると
その相互関係
まあ ヒンドゥー教では そこまで言ってなかったんだけど
お釈迦様は事実だから
強引に言わせちゃうんですね
そちらに
なぜならば
合理的に喋るならば
同じ答えが出ますから
そういうことで
仏教の違うところは どういうところですか
論理だけ 偉いというわけじゃなくて
めちゃくちゃ 口先だけで合理的に 喋ってもあまり気にしないんですね
驚かないと同時に
人は よくできて
性格は 良くて
素晴らしい人間であるならば
もう信頼してもいいと
人は信頼できないんだけど
口先でだけ 頭だけはすごく 動いているんだ と言ったら
そこはあまり信頼しないというかね
その点では 仏教の
違うところなんですね
ですから
僕らが言いたいのは
もうちょっと 合理的になってほしいですね
社会の人々は
ただ金儲けることではなくて
目的は 人々のために
幸福のために
自分の生きる目的ですか
objective of life という
この生活する目的は 変えなくちゃいけないんです
どんな人間でも
子供でも
みんなのために 生きてるんだと
みんなに 何かいいことを しなくちゃいけないんだ
これは 自分の仕事だと
それは 大人だったら 真剣に 考えなくちゃいけないんですね
仕事を 考える時でも
他のことを 考える時でも
やっぱり人の役に立つということ
そこら辺ですね
ちょっと変えてほしいと思うの
今は まだ知識のことばっかり 喋ってますけど
そういうのは 知識の世界で
智慧の世界っていうのは 随分違うんです
これ 何が違いますかというと
前も言ったように
同じ大学を卒業している二人が
どこかの同じ会社に入ったところで
何か 差が 現れてくるでしょ
どこかで
退職するまで 全くぴったし同じ
ということはないんですね
仕事をやっている間では
いろんな 差が出てくる
アメリカだったら ものすごく 差が出てくる
同じ学校を出て
同じ会社に 同じで入ったとしても
ある人は 副社長まで 上るかもしれません
ある人は ただ入ったまま
そのまま 社員だけで 残るかもしれませんし
まあ 日本は そんなに きつくはないんだけど
それでも差は あることは あるんですね
どこにあるんですか？と
それは 智慧の世界なんです
その差は
普段言う この能力の世界
それは 智慧の世界なんですね
もっと簡単に言えば
勉強は 誰にでもできますよ
それなりの勉強は
動物もやってますからね
猿もやってるでしょ？
いろんな芸なんか勉強して
ちゃんと 習ってやってるし
歌を歌う オウムもいるし
ちゃんとした日本語の歌とかね
それなりに
発音がちょっと 訛ってますけどね
オウム訛りが ありますけど
やっぱりそれでも がんばって歌ったりはするし
ですから
我が威張ってる この勉強っていうのは
そういうぐらいの 動物でも やってるんだから
別に そんなに大したことじゃ ないんですね
そこで問題は
この自分が得た知識
本人に使えるかないか
そこら辺から 智慧の世界
ですから
この世の中でみんな同じ教育を
受けているんだけど
ある人々は いろんなひらめきがあって
いろんなことを 作ったり
発明したりする
他の人は
あぁ 何か 自分も発明したらいいなぁ
たくさんのお金も入っちゃって
これでいいなぁ と思うだけで
いいなぁ いいなぁ でも 全然できない
何か人に
商売は 行き詰まってるんだけど
いいアイデアないんですか？
と言ったら
ある人は いろんな
バンバンアイデアを 出したりするし
他の人々は 同じ仕事を ずっとやっているのに
そうですね
今の状況では とか
ああだ こうだとか
もう 何時間
何年経っても なかなかいいアイデアが出てこない
もう 脳細胞は 動かないんですね
勉強しているんだけど
それはない
それは 智慧の世界なんです
そちらには 論理が ないんです
こういう風に考えれば
いいアイデアが 出ますよと
そういう 具体的な論理はないんです
それから
知識のためには
例えば 徹夜してものを覚えれば
次の試験で 何か合格できるかも しれませんけど
智慧の世界には
徹夜して 勉強したんだから
いいアイデアが出ましたよとか
そんなこと さっぱりないんです
だから 智慧のために 勉強しようが
酒飲んで寝ようが
そんなのは 関係ないんです
出る時は すぐバンバン出ると
アイデアが
わかりやすく 私は こういう風に
例えで 言うんですね
知識は 道具を集めること
ありとあらゆる 道具を集める
普通の方々が なさっていることでも
買い物を するわ するわ
何か新しい 新発売といっちゃったら
すぐ電話して 取り寄せてもらうとかね
物は買うんだけど
もう 2 、3年経ったら 何買ったか わからない
覚えてもない
あれ なんで これ家にあるんですか？と
不思議に思う時も あるんですね
道具は 買うんだけど
使おうとしないんですね
知識っていうのは 道具であって
いっぱいある
でも使い方は 知らない
使えないというのは 智慧が ないということで
ですから
智慧は すごい 極力実践的で
悪いということは 全くない
実践的だから
知識には いい知識
悪い知識は あるんです
智慧は ただ いいだけ
なぜならば
智慧っていうのは
何かのために 使うということだから
皆様 それでも 智慧がわからない と思うならば
こういう ケース 経験が あるでしょうかね
いろんな 家族関係やら 社会関係があって
例えば 学校を卒業できなかった
人々 いるんですね
ちゃんと 高校を卒業できなかったと
あるいは 中学も もう何とかあって
一応 義務教育だから 出たんだけど
結局 いろんなことがあって
勉強できなかったとか
それなのに
よく がんばって かなり 裕福になったりして
会社なんか 作ったりして
それまた たくさん いろいろ社員がいたりして
なんか そういう人々いるでしょ
我々の 社会で
そこで自分が 大学卒業してる人々を 雇うんですね
雇って その人々は その社長が
言う通りにやるだけであって
社長は 大学卒でもないのに
よく 新しいアイデアを出したりして 行動する
それ その差があるんですね
それ どういう差かというと
まあ 知識はないんだけど
ひらめきは 思う存分ある
いわゆる 智慧の方が 働いている
論理はない 論理的な ああだこうだとかね
例えば 国際経済状態とか
これ 売ったら これぐらいで
これで これで ああだこうだ とかね
そこまでは 勉強してないんだから わからない
でも なんとなく 今頃
これやっちゃえばいいんじゃないかと
すぐ 知ってしまう
なぜか と言っても
本人に わからないかもしれません だけど
そういうふうな
論理いらない ひらめきの世界は
智慧の世界
智慧が なければ
知識は 全く 役に立たない
それ 例えで 言うならば
皆様は 例えば
1ヶ月間
毎日 新聞を頭から最後まで 丸暗記しましたと
1ヶ月間の新聞を 丸暗記したら
すごい 大したもんでしょ
全部 宣伝まで 全てのページを 丸暗記したら
テレビでも 出してくれるかも しれませんよ
すごい 暗記力だから
じゃあ あれで 何になるんですか？
何か 役に立ちますか？
何も 役に立たない
そこで 役に立つというのは
何か 覚えていることが 生きるために 必要な時だけ なんですね
ですから
知識っていうのは 使えなきゃ 何の意味も ないんです
そこで 知識は どのように 使えるか というのは
智慧の 世界で
ですから 皆様にも 知識もあって 智慧もあるんです
普通 言うでしょ
生活の智慧 とか 生きる智慧 とか
それは この 仏教の 専門用語では ございませんが
智慧には 変わりはないんです
生活の 智慧だから
経験から得る 智慧とか
だから ありがたいのは どっちですか？
ありがたいのは 智慧の方なんです
今まで なんとか 生きているのは 生きていられるのは
わずかでも 智慧が 働いているからなんです
そうでなきゃ
本当に 迷惑な 存在なんです
人間 というのは
単なる 肩書きとか
いろいろ 何々大学出ました とかね
そんな いくらあっても
何も役に立たない場合は
何もできない場合は ただの 迷惑なだけです
智慧の方は 楽なんですね
でも 残念ながら
これには 論理が ないんだから
知識では 追おうとしたって
追えるものじゃない
掴めるもんじゃないんです
数学だったら ちゃんとした論理だから
まあ 2、3週間でも
1 ヶ月間でも 頑張っちゃえば
すぐ 身につくものです
音楽でも 体に慣らうものだから
まあ 一応 きついんだけど
頑張れば できるものなんですね
でも 智慧は そうじゃないんです
楽器は演奏できるんだけど
それを美しく演奏できるのは
本当に 素晴らしいこと できるのは
もうちょっと プラスアルファで 智慧が ある人なんですね
ピアノにしても
どんどん打つということは
まあ ちょっと勉強すれば できるんです
でも ピアノから いい曲を 演奏して
人々を 感動させよう ということは
もう ちょっと 違う働きなんです
それは 智慧の働きなんです
全ての 世界に それはあるんです
ですから
科学は みんな勉強するんだけど
科学者は 少ない ですね
みんな 宗教も 哲学も
まあ 日本ほど ヨーロッパの哲学を
勉強する国が ないんだから
ヨーロッパ人も そこまでやりません けどね
まあ 日本語訳 簡単に読めますからね
カントやら ああだ こうだと よく読みます けどね
一人も 哲学者いないんですね
ですから
勉強は できるんだけど
それは 智慧がないと 自分のものに ならないんです
私の話は 一番 世の中で危ない
毒舌 ばっかりで
それは 全然 智慧がなくて
使ってみてください
知識だけで 殺されるかも しれません
僕は わざわざと そういうふうに
この毒舌を 言ってるんです
なぜならば
僕らに とっては
皆様方が 智慧を発揮してこなきゃ
仏教でも 何でもないんですね
幸福には なりっこないんです
ですから
僕は 大胆な
爆弾的な
危ない言葉っていうのを 平気で言うんです
それを 消化できるのは 智慧がある ならば
まあ この人 こう言っても
まあ こういう こういうことでは ないかと
自分に 智慧があると それがわかる
人に 話してあげることも できる
たまに 僕に 文句言う場合も ありますね
私が言うことに 自分が すごく納得して
自分の個人的な いろいろな問題も なくなっちゃって
大変いいと思ってますよと
それを 自分の父親も
同じ問題で 悩んでいるのか
言われたところで 怒られたんだと
バカにされたんだと
あれ 何ですか？と
僕に 聞くんですね
それは 僕は 考えるのは
それは その通りだと
いくら私が言った言葉を
その通りに 自分の父親に 言ったとしても
ただ 知識を言ってるだけだから
全然 通じないんです
それ バカにされますよ
そうされるように
僕は すごいきつい言葉で 言ってるんだから
もし 自分に身に付いて 自分の智慧が
生まれたならば 通じるんです
教える場合でも
先生になって
教科書を きめ細かく砕いて
いろいろ教えても
全然 受けませんね
大体 学生っていうのは
そこら辺に やっぱり 自分の智慧で 調理した方が
調味料は 自分の 智慧なんですね
智慧という 調味料を入れちゃうと
もう 受け入れちゃうんですね
そこで 我々 楽しいのは 智慧なんです
知識は 苦しい
学校で 教えるのは 苦しいんです
でも 自分で いろんな工夫をして いろんなひらめきがあって
その ひらめきを使って 教える時は
なんとなく楽しい充実感が生まれる
勉強するのは 大変苦しいことなんです
いろんな本を 読まなくちゃいけない
メモを 書かなくちゃいけない
書いたメモを 忘れても 意味がないんだから
覚えておかなくちゃいけない
整理しなくちゃいけない
それでまた 忘れないように
またまた いろいろなことを やらなくちゃいけない
大変 きついです
勉強は 知識は
でも 智慧は きつくなく
すごく楽しい
疲れが 飛ぶ
飛んでしまっちゃう
出てこない
ですから
知識と同時に智慧も得ておけば
大変 幸福な 世界ができてくるんです
人が不幸というならば
智慧がない ということで
勉強していないんだから 不幸っていうのはない
大学卒業しなかったんだから
不幸というのはない
やっぱり いろんなひらめきがあって
智慧がある人は 幸福で
智慧がない人は 不幸であるんです
ですから
智慧の定義だけで 終わりますけど 話は
ちょっと 一部を 終わりにして
ちょっと短くして話しますけど
智慧はそういう定義で
言葉はない
智慧の世界に 論理はない
ロジックはないし
それから わざわざ得ようとしても
得られるものでもないんです
ひらめきみたいなもので
ただ ボンボン 浮かぶだけで
自然に 何か問題があったら
あっ そうだったら そうしよう と
すぐ パッと 浮かぶだけで
計画立てる 必要はない
知識の 全部 反対なんですね
覚える 必要はない
計画立てる 必要はない
メモを取る 必要はない
勉強する 必要もない
論理もいりません
でも 浮かぶ
じゃあ 智慧と道徳は どんな関係かというと
道徳を守らない
ものすごい いい加減な 生活をすると
大変 精神的に 乱れるんです
そうすると 確実に 智慧が 働かなくなっちゃうんです
ですから
智慧にも 道徳は 無視することは できない
例えば バリバリ仕事ができる 男性の方が元気で
一生懸命 他のどっかの若い 女の人に 恋してみてください
奥さんのことを忘れて
どうなるんですかと
どんどん仕事 できなくなっちゃうんです
仕事に集中できなくなっちゃうんです
そこで 会社から いろいろ 言われるようになるんですね
家にいても
もう 家で普通の夫として生活する 智慧が出てこなくなっちゃうんです
すると いろいろ混乱が 生まれちゃうんです
すると どんどん エスカレートして
不幸になっちゃうんです
ちょっとした 道徳の乱れでも 結構 智慧に効くんです
だから 智慧のために
智慧を作るために
いつでも すごく 明るく ニコニコと
ストレス 全くなく
楽しく 生活しなくちゃ いけないんです
すごく 心を 明るくして
明るくと また 軽く
知識から いろんな悩み
苦しみ ストレス 溜まっちゃうんです
ストレスが 溜まれば 溜まるほど
智慧が 機能を 失っていっちゃうんです
だから もうそこで 最後に これを 覚えておいてください
知識は きつく 疲れるもので
智慧は 楽しく 楽なもので
知識は 勉強して 覚えなくちゃ 忘れるもので
智慧の場合は 勉強するものも 何もないんだ
忘れることも 何もないんだ
そのまんまであって
知識は 努力すれば 得られものであって
智慧っていうのは 努力しなくても
関係なく どんどん現れるものであって
知識からは 幸福になるか 不幸に
なるかは はっきりしないんですね
いわゆる 道具ですから
それは うまく使うか 悪く使うか
でも 智慧の場合は 必ず 幸福をつかめるんです
知識には 言葉があり
智慧には 言葉がない
知識には 論理があって
智慧には 論理はなしと
ですから
科学は 知識の世界で
智慧は 科学ではありません
そういうところで
まあちょっと 一旦 難しいんだから
皆様に 智慧があるならば 問題ないんだけど
まあ ないわけ ないんだけども
智慧があるならば
私が話す必要ないですから
一旦 ちょっと
10 分ぐらい 休憩して
10分でもいいし
15分でもいいし
20分でもいいんです
[第2部]
じゃあ
2回目の智慧の いくらか
具体的に どうやれば
智慧が 生まれるかっていうことを
説明した方が いいだろうと 思います
一つは もう 考える世界じゃないんだから
とにかく 何も考えないで
しっかり 目をさめておく 時間を作れば
目が 冴えている さめて じゃなくて
僕はいつも 冴えていることを さめて と言うんだけど
よく 目が冴えて 頭が しっかり冴えているんだけど
瞬間だけ 何も 考えないで
何にも 考えないで 瞬間だけ 居てみる
難しいんです
ですから
もし 考えちゃったら
また 違いますよと
また 考えないようにしますと
そこで 眠くなっちゃったら ダメなんです
すっごく 目が冴えている状態で 何も 考えないでいる
こういうのは 日常生活の中でも 経験が あると思いますね
例えば 仕事行って疲れて
熱いお風呂に入ってちょっと瞬間 いるとすごい気持ちいいんですね
立ち上がったら 何か今悩んでいた問題とか あったならば
さっと それに 答えが出たりとかね
あるでしょ？
何にも考えないで
ほんの 瞬間でも いたならば
すぐ 心が それに 必要な智慧を出してくれる
だから 今日も ちょっと 休憩あげたんだけど
その休憩の中で 何にも考えずに 目を閉じて じーっといたならば
次の第2部の勉強に必要な力も ひらめきも ついてくるんです
ですから
頑張れば 知識は得られますけど
その頑張るという 余計に頑張る ということをストップすると
智慧が 生まれてくる
必要なのは 智慧なんです
でも 智慧があっても 道具がなければ 動きませんね
運転は できるんだけど
車が ないんだと
じゃあ 運転できないんですね
ですから
ただ 何もしないで
怠けていても
それは 智慧でもなんでもないんだけど
やっぱり それなりの 材料が
知識として 必要なんですが
知識のために 努力する
智慧のために 頑張るということを やめて 休むということをする
哲学者の 話を 聞くと
何もしないで
ただ すごい哲学ばかり 喋ってる人々の話
ギリシア哲学者とか 出てくるでしょ
あれは 智慧は働いてますけど
知識は 使ってないんですね
だから どこかで 何もしないで
そういう なんか 変な状態には なりますけどね
まあ 必死に 努力するんじゃなくて
心を ちょっと 休ませてあげる ということは
智慧が 現れるために 一つの必要な条件
ものすごく必要な条件というよりは
一つ 必要な条件なんです
もう一つは
物事を 信じないことなんですね
それ 悪い言葉で言えば 信じないこと何ですが
何でも信じるのは バカなんですね
あっそう  あっすごい とかね
あっ信じますよ とか
智慧が 生まれてこないんです
自分で 努力しないんです
ですから
普通のことを 勉強したり
普通に 生きている場合は
生きている間では
人が言うんだから 何でも 信じるんじゃなくて
それは 本当に その通りか ないかと
ちょっと 頭で 自分で 判断しようとする
心の怠け癖を とってほしいんです
例えば テレビで 何か言ったら
すぐ みんな そうですよと いきなり
そこは 良くない
そうすると 言われるどおりに ただの 操り人間になるだけで
智慧が 生まれてこない
だから 本当なのかとね 本当かな とかね
まあ ちょっとだけ 自分でも それは 考えてみる
それは 子供から 大人まで みんなに 必要なものなんです
ちょっと 自分で判断しようとする
何か セールスマンが来て 物を売ろうとすると
「これだったら すごいんですよ」と すぐ 決めちゃったら
必ず そこで やられちゃうんですね
そういうことを 本当かなと聞くと
自分に 聞くと
その 欠点の方も 見えてくるんです
同時に 自分に 智慧も 生まれてくる
ですから
2番目の方法 っていうのは
そういうふうに 物事を すぐそのとおりに
人が 言うとおりに
耳に 入るとおりに
飲み込むということは ストップして
ちょっとした 腰を入れるんです
自分でも もうちょっと 考えてみる
完全に 考えてみる 必要はないんです
それは 不可能なんです
例えば
なんとかテレビで
どこかの 湧き水があります
それ 飲んだら 美容にいいんですよ と
それを 片っ端から 自分で行って 試して
研究するっていうことは 不可能ですからね
他のものについても
外国のニュースとか いくらでも 出ますけど
それを 何でもかんでも
我々は 片っ端から 自分で 判断しますよと
あなた方の判断は 大きなお世話ですよと 思っても
そんな 何でもかんでも できるわけないんですね
ですから
あまり 厳密に じゃなくて
聞くもの 見るもの について
ちょっとだけ 自分でも 考えてみる
例えば ゴッホの絵は すごい綺麗ですよと
モネの絵は すごいんですよと 言うと
みんな そう思っちゃうでしょう
あれは 私だったら すごく 腹が立つんです
無知そのものだから
自分でも 感じてみろと
自分の 本心で 汚い絵だと思ったら
それでいいんです
別に 言わなくても
人に 合わせて すごいですね
やっぱり さすが ゴッホだ とかね
そんな もう無茶苦茶な
何の意味もない話を 言ってもいいんだけど
心の中で なんだ 汚い絵だな とかね
自分の判断だから
それやったら ものすごい 抜群の 知識人に
智慧の人に なっちゃうんです
それで ストレスもないんです
あの 自分で判断する瞬間で
心の ストレスは 全部消えちゃうんです
この 智慧が生まれる瞬間で
智慧こそが ものすごく強力な
癒す機能を 持ってるんです
知識は 体を壊す機能を 持ってるんです
ですから
2番目として 僕に言えるのは
常に 目が いつでも 冴えておいて 頭はね
ほんのちょっと自分でも 考えてみる
ですから
悪い言葉で 言うならば
何でもかんでも 丸呑み 鵜吞みで 信じるなと
みんな その他大勢と一緒になって
わいわいと 言っちゃうでしょう
それは もう
人間らしくもないし
動物と同じで
智慧のある人じゃないんです
とにかく
自分で行動できない
ですから
みんな 黒い色を 着ているんだったら
自分も さっさと行って
黒色の服を買って着るとか
みんな 髪を長くしているな とわかったら
じゃあ 私も髪を長くしなくちゃ とか
そういう その他大勢が やっていることを やっているのは
もう ただの操り人間で
ロボット文化で 機械文化で
人間の文化ではないんです
それは すごい苦しいんです
みんなの 真似しなくちゃいけないんだから
それ ごまかしちゃうんですね
日本は 和の社会だと
和の社会っていうのは 大変高度な 素晴らしいことで
和を守るためには よっぽど人間が
できていないと できないんです
そんな 簡単単純なこと じゃないんです
我々が 和 和というのは 和ではなくて
ただ 情けないというか
腰抜けというか
自信がないというか
逃げるんですね
あれは 和じゃないんです
ただの 腰抜けなんです
ですから
日本の 和の文化 っていうのは
それは もう最高の 素晴らしいことなんです
それは 腰抜け性格で ごまかしてはいけないんです
ですから
その他大勢と 一緒に 行動するんじゃなくて
自分の行動に 自分で 責任を持つ
ですから
モネの絵でも ゴッホの絵でも 何でもいいんだけど
みんな 綺麗と言うんだから綺麗 とは決めないで
本当かなと どうかなと 考えてみてください
私は 今 知識の話で
社会に対して いろいろ悪口を言ったでしょう？
屁理屈だらけだ ああだ こうだ とかね
ああいうのは 別に私は腹が立って 悪口言ってるわけじゃなくて
本当かな と考えたら
すぐ 違う側面も 見えてくるだけのことなんです
資本主義の経済こそだというと
僕は 本当かな と見たところで
資本主義の国々では ものすごい貧富の差があったりして
こんなに 日本にしても
ホームレスの家族が どんどん 増えていったりしていて
ですから 悲しいでしょう
ものすごく お金かかるんですね
日本で 生きるためには
1ヶ間 すごい膨大なお金が かかってしまうんですね
そうすると 普通の人間には 生きていられないんです
鬼みたいに 金を儲けなきゃ
それは いいですかね
鬼みたいに 金を儲かるためには
鬼の親分みたいに 自然を 破壊しなくちゃいけないんですね
自分自身も 破壊しなくちゃいけないんですね
それで やっと生きてるだけで
だから 一概に これはいい これは悪い とは言えない
それが 思い浮かぶのは
ちょっとだけ 本当かなと 思った時なんですね
別に 攻撃的というわけじゃ ないんです
人が これは
美味しいんだから食べてくださいって
言っちゃったら
いきなり どんと口に入れるんじゃなくて
ちょっと どうかな という感じで 口に入れてみる
我々は 固定概念で 食べてますからね
有名だと フランスで 食べてるんだと 聞いたら
何でも 食べてしまう
臭いものでも
すごく 美味しいものでも
アジアとか アフリカとか どこかで 食べてるとわかったら
あんなものは 日本人の口に 合わないと 平気で 言うんです
食べたこともないのに
フランスのものだったら
カビ生えたものでも 虫がいるものでも食べる
あれ 食べてみてください
全然 美味しくないんです
虫が入ったりとか
カビが入ったりとか
食べるのは 食べられないのは
それは 個人の 自由なことだから
別に どうでもいいんだけど
僕は ここで 智慧のことを 言ってるんだから
ちょっと 自分でも 物事を 試してみましょうと
そうすると 智慧が育ってくるんです
智慧っていうのは
もしかすると
このまあ
邪教ですか
外道の教えから言うならば
ジャイナ教とかね
そういう教えから 言うならば
自然にあるものなんです 完全に
ただ 我々は それに
苔がいっぱい出てきて
邪魔しているだけなんです
知識で 現れないように
ですから
くだらない 知識や 概念から
心が 綺麗になって リラックスすればするほど
本来の智慧が 表に出るんだと
もともとあった 智慧は
そこら辺にも いくらか筋は 通ってるんです
っていうのは
智慧っていうのは 別に 育てるものじゃないんだから
ただ 現れるために 機会 場を 与えてあげる
ですから
2番目に 言ったこと
物事を ちょっと 自分でも ほんのちょっと考えてみる
本当かなと
そう言っても ちょっと 危険性あるんです
ただ単に 反対しようと
何でもかんでも
それは 何の意味もないんです
世の中のことは 片っ端から 批判してやろうではないかと
それは 知識の世界で
どこか 心が 病気なんですね
世の中のこと
何でもかんでも そうだ そうだ
その通りだと言って 和を 守ろうというのは
どこか 病気なんですね
どこか 自信がないんだから
そういうものじゃないんです
ただの 反対ではなくて
ほんの かすか 遊びで 本当かなと ちょっと考えてみる
それは とことん 本当ですから
試すことは できないものであるならば
そこら辺で ほどほどに 置いておく
まあ わからないんだと
テレビで言ってるんだから
もしかすると 本当でしょう
もしかすると 嘘でしょうと
そういうふうに 置いておく
テレビの文化っていうのは
ものすごく 嘘を言う文化なんですね
映像の 文化だから みんな 信じちゃう
逆に それは 嘘の文化なんです
なぜかというと この間
アメリカが侵略していた 日本の方々が
よく観光に行く所ですけど
フィジー？　どっちかな？
そちらから アメリカは 手を引いて
援助もしないようになってるんですね
あと 3年経ったところで
今まで 普通の海で魚取って
ものすごく 楽に生活していた人々は これから
全くアメリカ式になったのだから
大変なことになるんですね
そこで 収入は 全くないし
タロイモと魚取って 食べていたんですけど
誰も 今 タロイモを 食べないんだそうで
みんな 缶詰ばっかり食べて 海の魚 食べない
缶詰の魚食べる
もう 2、3回同じ番組を 放映しましたけど NHKで
それで 人員削減というか
仕事といえば 全部 公務員だけ
政府の仕事だけで
そこで 4分の3ぐらい クビにしなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことで
それは 事実なんですけど
それは
口で言ったってわかりません
それで 映像が 流れるんですね
ある 何か事業の設計なんかして やってる立派な人が
市長ですか 村長か 誰か わかりませんけど
誰か 責任者のところに 呼ばれるんですね
そこでちゃんと
向こうは 来て
こっちは ポンポンと
ドアを叩いたりして
そこで 中に入って
その問題についてしゃべる
あなたを クビにするか
しないかということ
そこで映像で
NHKで 撮っている
あれは もう完全に 嘘なんです
やらせなんです
なぜならば
そんな大事なことっていうのは
いきなり テレビカメラが 行った時にしゃべるってこと
ありっこないでしょう
そういうことっていうのは
突然 ある日 現れた 問題ではなくて
アメリカも ちゃんと相談して
もう これからは あなた方の 面倒を見れませんと
我々は もう そこら辺で 軍隊 やったって 意味がないんだから
我々のために 引き上げますよと
あと 3年で 援助が切れますよ ということは 前からあった話で
ですから
どうしよう どうしようかと
何年も そういうことを 考えてきて
クビになったら
誰が クビになるんでしょうか
私が クビになるぞ
あの人 クビになるぞ
そういう話は いっぱいありまして
自分の下で 働いている 人々のことというのは
政府は 自分で ちゃんとした場で それは 考えていますよ
ディスカッションしますよ
テレビカメラの前で きちんと座って
まあそうですね
別に あなたを 特別にクビにしたい という口実は ないんですけど
じゃあ どうすればいいんだ
それはまあ
単なる 正真正銘の やらせなんですね
でも 普通の 智慧でないと
見ても それは 気がつかないんです
本当は あれは 面白い番組じゃなくて
ちゃんとした ドキュメンタリーなんです
ちゃんとした ドキュタリーであろうとも
90% 映像は信頼できないんです
ですから
だからといって 僕は その国の 真実を知ってますかと言えば
全然知りません
名前も はっきり 思い出せませんからね
僕にとっては
名前はどうでもいいんです
僕は 智慧の働きだけ 考えているんだから
ただ こんな 現代社会の
テレビニュースであっても
やっぱり 信頼性は 欠けているんだと
新聞の方が 活字だから
人が 勝手に 考えるんだから
その場合は 個人がね
いくらか 信頼性があるんだけど
いくらか
でも その場合も 信頼性ないんです
なぜならば 事実があって
記者がいるんですね
記者が自分に把握できたものしか
メモを取らないんですね
それで 読む人々がどうやって 読んで 面白がってくれるのか
読む人々のことを 想像しちゃうんですね
そして 作品書くんです
ですから
新聞というのは
その記者たちの 勝手な作品であって
その中に 漏れちゃうんですね
事実 いくつか
ただ それだけ
それで 我々は 新聞記事に あったのではないかというふうに
すごく それは 証拠に出すんです
智慧っていうのは
そういうふうに
裏のからくりを 知ることなんです
カーテンの向こう側を ちょっと開けてみる
ちょっと 覗いてみると
どうなっているんですかと
その 気持ちなんですね
ですから
見るもの 聞くもの
そのまんま 鵜吞みにするんじゃなくて
本当かなと
どうかなと
ちょっとした 明るい 気持ちで
ほんのかすかに 自分で 考える
いわゆる 自分の意見も持つ ということなんですね
ちょっと 考え直してみる
そうすると
また いろんな 違うものが見えてくる
それで すごく 面白い
自分で 発見するものだから
その 面白さによって すごく リラックスもできる
元気にもなる
それから 仕事にもなる
仕事に 必要なのは
物事を 言うとおりに やってくれる ロボットでは ありません
経済状態が きちんと動いているならば
ロボットで 結構です
経済状態が ちょっとガタガタに なってくるとロボットでは困るんです
新しいものを 考え出して
新しく チャレンジして
新しく 競争する人々が 必要なんです
だから 今まで ヨーロッパの方は 経済的に 力強くて
アメリカの方が すごく 経済状態が良くて
日本のものは 何でも買っちゃうと
そこで 日本は すごい経済成長
経済成長と謳っていたんだけど
アメリカが ちょっと ストップと言ったところで
もう ぐるぐると 倒れちゃうでしょう
なんで 世界一流の強い国が
ちょっと一言で 倒れるんですかね
そこは 良くないんですね
倒れるということは
だから
あ 状況変わったよと
状況が変わったならば
この 経済状態を どうやって 維持しますか？
という場合は
ロボットでは ものすごく困るんです
朝きちんと
30 分 1時間早く 会社に行って
仕事がなくても
1 時間半ぐらい 会社に留まっていて
家に帰る連中は ただの迷惑なんです
じゃなくて
ああしたら いいんじゃない
こうすればいいんではないかと 文句ばっかり言っている
この嫌な人々は
その時は 助けになるんです
じゃあ こうしようと
じゃあ この商売を この会社を 潰しましょうと
潰しちゃって
もう 新しいことを 作ろうではないかとか
そうすると 生き延びることというか
生存することは できるんですね
だからやっぱりなんだかんだ言っても
必要なのは 智慧なんです
ひらめきの世界なんです
仕事で 困った 困った という人々は
ほとんど この智慧がないというか
使わないというか
そこで問題を作ったりするんです
智慧がある場合は
どんなくだらない仕事でも 面白おかしくやることはできるんです
まあ 一応 2番目はちょっと長く言いましたけど
大事なポイントで
ちょっと 自分でも考えてみる
考えてみて
そこから現れた 智慧でもいいし 知識でもいいし
それもまた 持っていく
自分のものとして
そうすると
3つあるんです
一つは 自分の知識
もう一つは 社会から入る情報
社会からの情報は もう判断して入れてくれるんですね
これは 素晴らしいニュースだ
これは 悪いニュースだと
判断すでにしているんです
記者であろうか
まあ そういうレポーターする人々が
自分の浅い智慧で 知識で
ですから
我々には すでに持っている知識と
入ってくる知識と
自分で作った ただ 自分だけの知識ってあるんですね
自分で判断したものもありますから
世の中で誰にもない自分だけのもの
その３つを一緒に並べておくと
パッと何か浮かんじゃうんです
それは智慧なんです
そういう風に 常に 自分で考えること
次に 言いたいのは
このワンパターンに マンネリとか ありますね
みんなそうなりたがっちゃうんですね
何かパターンを決めて
マニュアルを作って
そのとおりに 生きていきたいんですね
あれこそ 智慧に毒 はないんです
みんな 落ち着くんですね
毎日決まってる時間で起きて
決まってる食べ物を食べて
決まってる時間で家を出て
決まってる仕事をして
決まってる時間で帰って
決まってる店に行って酒を飲んで
決まってる時間で 家に戻ると
そこで 決まってる挨拶を交わして
決まってるパターンでお風呂に入って
布団を敷いて
決まってる人に布団敷いてもらって
そこで寝ると
もし 奥さんではなくて
ちっちゃな子供が 布団敷いちゃったら
どうせいい加減ですから
子供に できませんからね
それだったら 何かちょっと おかしくて 寝られないんですね
決まってること
ちょっと 変わりましたから
それだったら
人生は もう 智慧どころじゃないんです
それまた ロボット文化で
それは 良くない
ですから
私たちには この社会は 変えることできない
社会のことを 変えることは できないんです
例えば 会社は
9時に仕事が始まるんだったら
やっぱり自分は
朝4時に起きて 運動してるんだから
6時になっちゃうと
もう ご飯も食べて すごい元気ですよと
奥さんも いないですから
自分で 何か朝ごはん作って
もう食べて
5時から 起きて 運動して
6時には 食べて
もう汗も出て 元気なんですね
だから その場ですぐ会社に 行くことはできるんですね
だから 会社に文句言って ちゃんと
6時半から仕事を始めなさい というのはちょっとおかしい話で
迷惑であってね
そういうふうに 社会を 変えることは できないんです
会社が 9時だと決めているならば
9時に行けばいいんです
でも 私たち個人で
このパターンに はめられないように しなくちゃいけないんです
決まってるマンネリは
パターンは 一応 守ってはいるんだけど
精神的に はめられて
ロボットにならないように 気をつけなくちゃいけない
どういうことを 工夫すれば いいかと 具体的に 言うならば
何でも 新しいんだと
昨日は 昨日で
今日は 今日ですよと
昨日と同じく 今日もあるわけじゃないんだと
今日と同じく 明日も ということはないんだと
毎日 チャレンジだと
今日は 仕事うまくいったんだから
じゃあよし
元気つけて 自信があって
明日もやるぞと 思ったって
それは ちょっと危ない
今日うまくいっても
明日は うまくいかないかもしれません
今日叱られたんだから
明日も叱られるわけじゃないんです
ですから
常に 目が冴えておいて
目が開いておいて
知識の目を
毎日 物事は 違うんだと
同じ現象に
2度と 会わないんだと
いつでも 過去のものを 置いておいて
新しい 心を作って
じゃあ 今日出会うものに
一つ一つ チャレンジしていきますと
それ 終わっちゃったら
まあ 終わったんだから
じゃあ 次の問題と
この例は 良くないんだけど
コンベアベルト というものあるんですね
生産の 過程では
コンベアベルトの概念では
物は 流れてくるんですね
自分には 決まっている 仕事があるんですね
そこで さっさと 仕事をする
そこで 自分のところに届いた
品物に何かネジ一つ入れるとかね
あるいは 袋に入れるとか
何か 決まってる仕事 かもしれませんけど
それ やりながら どれぐらい流れてくるんですかね
たくさんありますねと
考えたら どうなるんですか？
こちらの仕事は できなくなっちゃうんですね
そこで そこを行ったものについて
ああ 今日はこれぐらい作ったな
まあ 結構やったね 我なりに とか思っちゃうと
こちらは もう全部
ですから
勝負は 瞬間だけであって
ここから流れるものはどうでもいいし
こちらから 出ている それは 関係ないんですね
だから 勝負は 今日ありと
全部 新しいんだと
それ 1週間頑張っていれば
その気持ちで 見違えるほど 人は生まれ変わっちゃうんです
とことん 頭に 叩き込んでおいて
瞬間 瞬間 新しいんだと
同じパターンで 物事起こるわけじゃないんだと
叩き込んで 世の中を見て 生きてみてください
1週間ぐらい
もう 人は 生まれ変わるんです
新しい 智慧の世界に
全く違うように 世の中が 見えてくるんです
残念ながら
何でもかんでも マニュアルどおりに
子供に ご飯作ってあげることも ちゃんとテキスト通りにと
子供を 躾けたい時も
ちゃんと 本のとおりにやろうとする
自分で 考えようとしない
だから 智慧は まるっきりなし
子供の 抱き方
おっぱいの あげ方まで 教えてくれるんだから
笑われちゃうんでしょうに
あれ 自然なことだから
自分の産んだ子に おっぱいは あげられませんというならば
教えなくても 何とかやりますよ
なんで あんな教育あるんですか
わからないんです
なんか 人間恨んでるでしょと 思いますけど 私は
人間恨んで 金を儲けようとしているんだからね
だから お母さんたちが
初めての子を 授かったところで
そういうところに行って お金を払って
いろいろ 指導を受けたりする
だからといって 完全に悪いわけじゃないんだけど
それなりに 役に立つ部分があるんだけど
あまりにも そういうものに頼っちゃうと
自分で考えなくても いいんですね
子供の料理の順番が全部
それなりのお医者さんか栄養士が
考えてリストを書いてるんだから
リストにあるものを あげればいいんです
あれで 智慧は生まれてこない
ものすごくつまらないんです 人生は
なぜならば 刺激がないんですね
生きてるんだと
例えば 自分で何か料理を工夫して作る
作って 赤ちゃんに 食べさせたところで
硬いものを 食べられるようになったところで
赤ちゃんが ひどい顔をして 食べなかったと
そうすると
あ これは失敗だという
あるでしょ 何か 勉強になるものが
そこで なんで赤ちゃんが あれを食べなかったんですか？
と考えたら
自分でも食べてみたら
やっぱりそれ 自分にも嫌という
じゃあ こういう風にしようと
それで 次の日やったところで
赤ちゃんが すごく喜んで
ニコニコ笑いながら食べたならば
自分もすごい
なんかどこかで 競争で勝ったような
1等賞を取ったような感じが するんじゃないんですか？
よく食べてくれたんだと
そういうふうに 瞬間 瞬間 新しいチャレンジがあるんです
例えば 赤ちゃんが泣くたびに
おっぱいあげるとかね
すごく くだらないんですね
そうじゃなくて
今はもしかすると お腹が空いてるだろうと
でもまあ 今はもうちょっと面倒くさいんだから
あと 10分経ったところで おっぱいあげますよと
でも赤ちゃんはお腹が 空いてるんだから泣いちゃうでしょ？
じゃあどうすればいいんですかと
いつでも泣くたびにオッパイあげるって いうわけじゃないんだから
人はいろいろまた 他の仕事もあるんだから
電車でおっぱいあげたって 何のこともないんだけど
自分が電車で立ってると
その時赤ちゃんが泣き出しちゃう
座ってるんだったら おっぱいあげられますけど
その瞬間でマニュアル通りには いかないでしょうに
自分で何か考えなくちゃいけない
何かして 赤ちゃんの意識を 他の方に向けて
なんとか騙さなくちゃ いけないんですね
泣かないように
そういうふうに人生っていうのは
ほんの瞬間
瞬間 我々に ひらめきが出てくるっていうのは
いつでも 瞬間 瞬間あるんですね
ですから
マニュアル文化を 蹴っ飛ばさない限りは
これは社会的に 蹴っ飛ばすんじゃなくて
個人の心は それに汚染されないように
マニュアル通りにやる
その方が安全だから
もしマクドナルドとか そういうファーストフードの店に
バイトにでも 行ったならば
どういうふうに ハンバーグを作るんですかと
ちゃんと 絵で描いてるんですね
そこで自分で じゃあ トマトを控えようとかね
もうちょっと からしを 多めに入れようとか
余計なことをしなくてもいいんです
その場合は 言ってる通りにやりながら
だからといって
自分の人生まで マニュアルにするのはおかしいんですね
ですから
やり方をわかりやすく言うならば
今日は 今日だけですと
毎日自分が出会う問題は 全く 新しいものだと
ですから
その場で 考えなくちゃいけないんだと
それに今までの経験と勉強と知識と 何でもかんでも 使うんだけど
結論は その場で出しますと
たまに 僕に言われる場合が ありますね
こういうふうに上司に言われたんだと
その場合は どうすればいいんですかと
僕は具体的な答えは 出さないんですね
なぜかというと
あなたは上司に そういうふうに言われた
その場合は こういうふうに 返事した方がいいよと言ったら
すぐそれを 鵜呑みにするんですね
それを覚えて
じゃあ次
上司にこう言ってあげますと 準備して行くんだけど
次の日は同じ言葉で 𠮟りませんから
だからせっかく私からもらった 智慧は役に立たないんです
そういうことだから
私は具体的な答えは出せません
具体的な答えを 出してほしい場合は
僕は みんなに言うのは
私を現場に入れてみてくださいと
現場でちゃんと 見せてみせます
具体的な例 どんな問題にでも
でも それを 猿真似したとしても
他の人には ダメなんです
その人は 自分で
その瞬間
自分が出合った問題に
ちゃんと対応しなくちゃいけない
例えば ある人の奥さんが ものすごくヒステリーを起こしちゃって
ものすごいトラブルを 起こしているんだと
そこでお坊さん 何か言って あげくれませんかと言ったら
ハイわかりましたよと 言って
その奥さんと話して 抑えることはできるんです
それを外から見ていた旦那が
よし その方法で私もやりますよと
これ冗談じゃないんです
それは うまくいかないんです
だから あまり具体的な例に 頼るんじゃなくて
具体的な例も使って 自分で判断しちゃう
そのために 必要なのは
物事は いつでも新しいんだと
今日の日は 昨日と違ってどうなるか
わからないチャレンジの日ですと
まあちょっとした何か ビクビクしたような感じで
学校の先生であろうか
もう 毎日行ってるんだから つまらないわ ではなくて
今日はどんなことに なることかと わからないんだから
まあ とにかく よし 行ってやるぞ という気持ちで 毎日行くと
毎日 面白いんです
智慧も生まれてくる
仕事にもなる
ストレスもないし
幸福も感じる
それは智慧を育てる 3番目の方法なんです
まあ 1週間ぐらい 厳密にやってしまえば
いきなり すごく 人が変わったほど 変わるんです
智慧の世界
4番目
指でも数えとかないといけないです
数えておいても
こうやっちゃって また忘れちゃう
物事には ちゃんとした 配列ですか
因縁関係というか
ちゃんと 順番のようなものがあるんですね
それは仏教でいう 因果法則なんです
いわゆる偶然というのは なし
何でも きちんとした 因縁によって 生まれてくるんです
ですから
何か問題に出会う瞬間で
すぐそこら辺に この問題が なぜ現れたかという
その すぐその場の 因縁がわかってくるんです
それを 発見してほしい
もっと違う言葉で言えば
現れる現象の からくりを 理解しようと
すぐ 瞬時に
前言ったでしょ？
ちょっと本当かなと
ちょっと見てくださいと
物事を そうやっちゃうと
1番目に言ったのは それでしょ
すぐ このからくりが 見えてくるんです
4番目として それを使うんです
からくり
こうでこうだから こうなったよと
すぐわかったら
すぐそこに 答えが出てくるんです
この前も こちらで 同じ例を申し上げましたけど
ある二人が 大喧嘩になったところで
一人は 喧嘩しませんけど
一人は怒って 散々 いろんなことを言うんです
そこで そこを見ていた もっと智慧のある人が
それに論理的に 合理的に 言おうとしなかったんですね
あなたは こうこう言っても
あの人は こうこうではないか
ああだこうだとか 言っても
怒りは 収めないんですね
いきなり あなたは正直者ものですからね
それだけ言ったんです
それで抑えたんです
どういうことかというと
この人は ある人のことを 気に入らなくて
もう悪口言ってるだけで
それは 決していけないことで
人の悪口は 自分だけ
まあ ああだこうだと
とにかく あの人が すぐわかったのは
その人は ものすごく物事を 自分には 上手にできるんだとかね
自分も やらなくちゃいけないんだとか
とにかく 自己を出したいんですね
自分を出したいんですね
なかなか出す場がなかったんで
それに 腹が立ってるんです
それに ずっと説法しても効かない
怒りを収めない
瞬時に それを わかってしまうんですね
やっぱり 自分に 立場が なかったんだから
今 怒ってるんだと
ですから
あの人は 正しいと 言うんじゃなくて
あなたも 正しいんだ と言うんじゃなくて
全く違うことを 言っちゃうんです
あんた すごい 正直ですねとか 何とか 言ったら
本人が わけわからなくなって
なんとなく 落ち着いちゃうんですね
一つは もしかすると この人は 私の言うことを 認めましたと 誤解するかもしれません
あるいは 私は正直者だと 言われたんだから
やっぱり 正直者は 立派な性格だから
私は 立派な 態度を 取らなくちゃいけないんだと
今の自分の態度は 立派じゃないんだと
いくらなんでも
人を批判することは 立派じゃないんだから
そういう 何かの働きが 働いて
瞬間に あの人の怒りが 消えちゃったんです
消えて問題は 解決
ですから
問題の 遠い原因を 探す必要はない
まあ ありますが
遠い原因を 探して 答えを出すと
1時間 1年ぐらいかかるんです
人は 今 問題を作っているんだから
今 答えを出さなくちゃいけない
特に 精神的な 問題の場合は
いろいろ 過去世まで遊ぶ 連中いるんですね
思い出させて
1年前 どうなったんですか？
2年前 どうなったんですか？
5年前 どうなったんですか？
10年前...
小さい時は どういうことですか？
とか そこでも原因見つからなかったら
過去まで人を なんとかさせたりしてとかね
それは 本当か嘘か わかりませんけど
かなり 時間がかかるんですね
そういう 精神的な治療に 行っちゃったら
今の悩み
今すぐ 治した方がいいんです
今 キャーキャーと やってるならば
なぜ 今こうなったんですか？
と 例えば
ある人が すぐ ヒステリーになるんだと
ちょっとしたことで
それは 小さい時の 経験かもしれませんよ
小さい時
何かあって
それで どんどん ヒステリー性格に
あるいは 多重人格に なっちゃったんだと
そこまでいって 治そうとするならば
5、 6年…。　7 、8年…。
大体 ほとんど 治りませんから
一生かかっても 治らないというかね
それよりは 生きているのは 今の瞬間だから
今の瞬間で
なぜ 今 ヒステリーになったのかと
すぐ見つかって それを 何とかしちゃう
例えば 人がある問題で ものすごくヒステリーになって
もう 私はこんなことを やっていられません
ああだこうだとかね
もう あの人と一緒に 仕事は 絶対できませんとか
何とかしてくださいとか
言うかもしれません
それで そう言ったとしても
会社は 会社だからね
あなたは 他のところに 行くわけにもいきませんし
その人は 他に転職するかと
そんな 簡単に できませんし とかね
いい加減だとか 言っても 意味がないんです
その場合
すぐあなた
ちょっと 他の何かあったら 頼めばいいでしょ
この資料を ちょっと向こうの
3階まで 持っていって
あの人に 渡してくれませんか？とかね
あるいは ちょっと買い物でもして
なんかケーキでも 買ってくれませんか
ちょっと ケーキ食べたかったんですけど
女子ですからね
言えるし
あのことと 何の関係ない何かを言ってあげると
そうすると すぐ落ち着く
すぐ その瞬間で 消えちゃうんですね
あの状態は
本人が 帰ってくると
文句も 何もなく
また 仕事に戻るんです
だから
すぐその瞬間で 答えを出して
そこで 問題を押さえてくれれば 十分です
また 問題を作ったら また抑えてあげちゃう
それを 何回か繰り返しちゃうと
その人は 簡単に治りますし
それでも 治らない場合は 一応 余裕があるんだから
トラブルは起こしません
起こしたら ここで 全部解決する
で 余裕があるんだから
ゆっくり 精神科のところに行って カウンセリングでも受けて
ゆっくり あなたの原因を 治してくださいと いうことも言えるし
だから この物事の配列というか
なぜ こんなことになったかと
ただそれだけ
見て すぐ それに答えを出すということも 一つの方法なんですね
これ ちょっと やりにくいかもしれませんね
一応 物事は 偶然には 現れません
自分の旦那さんが偶然
不倫するようになったと
ある日 突然というのは ないんです
それなりの 原因結果が まとめたところで そうなるんであって
そこら辺 知っていると
なんとか することは できるんです
ですから
お医者さんが やるような感じで
すぐ 何とかしなくちゃいけないんだよ
とにかく
あるいは 子供が 学校で喧嘩して
ものすごく カンカン怒って
もう怒りで 涙流して 家に来て
バーンと ドアを 開けて
靴なんか 捨てて あっち捨てて
部屋に入って いろいろ 親言うことも 聞かない
ああいう状態 たまに あるんですけど
そこでもう いちいち こっちで何ですか
その態度はとか
あそこだ とか言って
そうじゃなくて
今 怒っていて 混乱状態ですと
まず 混乱状態を 何とかしようと
人が 混乱して 怒っていると
何をすれば 治りますか？
簡単でしょ
その場合は
ちょっと 面白いことを 言ったりとかね
あるいは 考えたこともない 何か他のことを言ったりとか
あるいは 自分の子供だったら
ちょっと 頭なでてあげるとかね
どうですか？
とかね 何も 言葉かけなくてもいいし
たまに ちょっと スキンシップぐらいとかね
例えば 子供が 喧嘩して 血だらけで 泥だらけで来たら
なんでどういうことになった？
自分も ヒステリーに なっちゃうでしょ
それは危ない
そうじゃなくて
ああ やれやれと言いながら
ちょっと顔をね
拭いてあげるとか
こんな 可愛い顔も もう台無しですよとか
なんとか言いながら
あれぐらいで すごく じーんと 心落ち着いていくんです
何の原因も 探そうとしないで
あれだけで
まあ それから 子供は 自分で言い始める
実は今日はね
こういうことに なったんだよとか
ああだこうだとか
あ そう
だから すぐ そのことを やらないんだから
ほとんど 失敗しちゃうんですね
自分の子供が 喧嘩して うちに帰ったら
そのお母さんが すぐ次の日
家に行って
その家の子供に 喧嘩を売ろうと するんだからね
学校に行って 先生に 喧嘩を売ろうと するんだからね
私は 交友関係あるならば
全部 学校の先生たちに 教えてあげるんだよ
お母さんが 来たらぶん殴れと
何も聞かないで
そうすると 怖くて 学校に行かないんだから
だから みんな問題を 大きくするだけで
解決しようという 気持ちが ないんです
自分の子供が 殴られたら
すごい 自分の我が 出てきて
自分のプライドが 傷ついたんだと
そんな感じで行って
先生に悪口を言うわ
殴った子供に 悪口を言うわ
その両親に 悪口を言うわ
自分の 悩んでいる子供のことは 全然平気なんです
そうじゃなくて
泣きながら来たらね
ちょっとだけ ハグですか
まあちょっと スキンシップしてあげて
ちょっと 顔を拭いてあげて
髪の毛も ちょっとだけ
別に そんな大した意味が ないんだけど
それは 子供が 自分でやるかもしれませんけど
その時は
乱れてる服を ちょっと 直してあげたりとかね
なんか違うことをやって
あの状態を 慰めてあげる
そうすると もしかしたら 何のことも なくなるかもしれない
まあ 大したこと ないんですよと
子供は 言うかもしれません
子供が 大したことないと 言うならば
大したことはないし
ですから
余計なことを 考えるんだから
みんな どうせ 一般の社会っていうのは 理屈の社会じゃないんだから
その上 理屈だと思って さらに 変なことを考えちゃう
ですから
智慧が現れるために 言うのは
すぐその場で なぜこんなことが 起きたかとか
どうすれば こんな現象が 消えるかと
すぐ その場で なんとかすると
具体的な 例っていうのは わかりやすいんだけど
言っちゃったら
それまた 鵜呑みにして その通りにやろうと 思っちゃうとね
困りますから
あまり 使えない 例しか 僕には出せないんですね
仏教の立場から言うならば
物事の因果関係を知ると
因果関係を知ったならば
この果 この結果は この原因で現れたと 知ってますからね
そこで この結果は 次にこういう結果の原因になるんだと 知ってます
だから 今の状況は 変えなきゃいけないんだと
現在の 果 状態
悩んでいる子供の 喧嘩してくる子供の
その 今の状態だけ 変えてあげれば 大丈夫なんです
いろいろ相談
ディスカッションして
子供の性格やら 学校の行き方
教え方 そこまで 行かなくてもいいんです
みんな そこら辺ちょっと 何かおかしいだけですけど
あまり 遠く 遠くまで 走っちゃうんです
それも必要だけど
それには 時間の余裕が 必要なんです
例えば 怒ってきた子供は
すぐ帰ったら すぐ家の中で
もし 母が 何か引き金を引いたならば 爆発しちゃうんです
そこで 一旦家の中で 暴力を振るったならば
次の結果も 必ず 決まっているんですね
だから この学校の教育 うんぬんとか
教室の仲間のこと うんぬんとか
そんなことを 喋る暇がある？
よくあるんですね
みんなに
そうじゃなくて
すごく 怒りで カンカンになった子は
母も 無責任に なんか言ったら 爆発するんだから
まず その火を消すと
それなんです 大事なのは
僕は自分の例なんですけど
ある日 ちっちゃな子供二人が すごい喧嘩して
もう服は むちゃくちゃ
になっちゃって
破れちゃって
泥だらけで
雨の中で 何の訳もなく 喧嘩して
そこで 一人は すごい喧嘩したがる
ものすごい
なんかもう 蜂みたいな
ちょっとしたことで 攻撃するんです
僕らの言葉でも 蜂と言うんです
すぐ喧嘩する 人々は
で まあ
もう一人の子は 別にそんなわけじゃないんだけど
とにかく喧嘩になっちゃう
大体 落ち着いてる人なんですね
喧嘩の引き金を作るのは
我々は 逆に思ってますけどね
どうせ性格が悪い人は どうせ性格が悪いんだから
別に何のことないんです
それ 誰かが 何か言うんですね
何か言っちゃったら
こっちはもう すぐ爆発しちゃうんです
だから 全然 よく勉強できて
性格良くて 落ち着いてる子だけど
いつでも 喧嘩的な人に 何か言っちゃうんだから
その何か言ったことで 爆発して ぶん殴られて 怪我して
そうすると 先生たちが 素晴らしい いい子を 殴ったんだと
こいつは 前々から 悪いんだと言って
あの人の 立場を 取っちゃうんです
どうせ 心の中でも
それで 問題解決しない
そういうケースの場合
僕に 実際に会った瞬間で
僕には その解決する暇もない
忙しくて 忙しくて
子供の扱いは 他の人々に 任せてあったし
その人々には もう 手に負えないんですね
あんまりにも 喧嘩やってるんだから
もう 仲介できないほど ちっちゃいんだから
別に 二人とも 捕まえたら もう終わりますけど
それでまあ 大人が行って
もうやめなさい と言って 二人分けたら 終わったんだけど
それでも もう捕まってるのに 相手 蹴飛ばそうとしてるんですね
で どうしようもないんだから
離すわけにはいきません
離しちゃったら またやっちゃう
ですから
二人で このちっちゃな子供二人を 捕まえて
どうせずっと 捕まえっぱなし ダメですし
どうしようもなく 私のところに 連れてきたんです
私は他のことをやって
僕は何のことなく
あの 誰が悪い人か
誰がいい人かと関係なく
二人とも もう口を準備しているんですね
これから ちゃんと 自分の立場を 正しいと言ってやろうと
弁解 しようではないかと
僕は それも聞かなくて
やれやれ
なんだお前
泥だらけで まあ汚くて
そこから 全く違う方向に 問題を 持っていったんですね
いわゆる その子供のことを
心配しているところに 持っていったんですね
君は 泥だらけで汚くて
ああ 嫌だなとかね
言うのは 親の心だから
やっぱり 綺麗にいてほしい という気持ちだから
それは ちゃんと 子供に通じるんですね
そこで 捕まえてきた人に
あんた この子ちゃんと洗ってあげてよと
なんのこともなく
それで洗ってあげたんです
次の子も同じく
それほど 汚れてなかったんだけど
それも ちゃんと 拭いてあげたりして
で 終わっちゃうと
まあもう家に帰ってね
着替えてこい
それだけ
それで 問題終わりと
誰が悪いか
誰が正しいか
そんなことは 別にどうでもいい
問題は 解決だから
それっきり もう あの二人は 喧嘩にならない
あの子は ものすごく いい子に なっちゃったんだから
あんな 喧嘩的な子は 今 大きいんだけど
今 あまりにも おとなしくて
今度行ったら僕は
お前おかしいでしょうと
喧嘩するんだったら 今でしょうと
ふざけて 悪ガキやるんだったら 今でしょ
今 もうそろそろ 十六か 十五歳ぐらいなんですね
まだ 体は 小さいんだけど
遊び回るんだったら 今でしょ
今 おとなしくなって どうするんですかと
そう言われるぐらい 落ち着いてるんですから
ちょっとしたことで
ですから
それ 私のやり方で
だからといって子供は
じゃあ 喧嘩したら 洗ってあげようとか
決めるんじゃないんです
だから 具体的な例は 言いたくないんです
僕は すぐ読むのは
やっぱり
いくらなんでも 子供っていうのは
やっぱり 自分のことを 心配してくれると
その人には ちゃんと 反応する ということなんですね
心配してくれる人々は 裏切ってはいけないんだと
それぐらいは 本能として 知ってるんです
だから 正直に 心配してあげる
それは 行動にも 表してあげる
余計な行動ではなくて
必要な時
行動でも示す
同じ子のこと なんですけど
ある日 お母さんが 私に 子供のことを 言うわ言うわ
子供 いるんですね
本当にもう こいつは もう嫌ですよ
言うこと 聞かない
ああだこうだ 喧嘩するは 勉強しないとかね
もう 人生まで 嫌になっちゃったんだと
散々 子供の悪口を 私の前で言うんですね
私と子供は いくらか 仲がいいということは 知ってるんだから
信頼して 言うんですけどね
だとしても
子供にとっては すごい 自分の プライドが傷つくでしょう
先生にあげますから
もう何でもいいんで 何とかしてくださいと
私は 嫌ですよとか
母親が そんなことを 言っちゃうと
僕は そんなこと 言うなんて
いかに 子供に対して 失礼かと
思いつつ 黙っているんですね
何も反応しない
答えない
そちらに
川があったんです
川を渡る橋があったんです
みんな車でいたんです
そこで 僕はいきなり運転手に
ちょっと 車 停めてくださいと
橋のところに
いきなりだから 何の意味もないんだからね
まあ何ですか？
と言ったら
何ですか？
いえ こいつを この川に捨てたいんですよと
僕の反応
それだけなんですね
じゃあ 停まってください
こいつを 今 このまま 川に 捨てますからと
そう言っちゃったら
やっとお母さんも落ち着いちゃって
子供も 気持ちよく なっちゃったんですね
今まで 母親が 自分に 恥かかせて
恥かかせて
もし 私が そのまま 鵜吞みにしちゃったら
あの子は 私にも 会わせる顔が ないんだから
で それに いきなり 僕の反応は
じゃあ 川に捨てよう
そこに すごくユーモアが あって
子供は 可愛いという 表現があるでしょ
それは 川に捨てよう ということは
別に 川に捨てる 意味じゃないんだから
誰もそんなことしないし
あの子も 今 いろんなことを お母さん言ってもね
あまり聞いてないんだと この人は
そこでやっと その二人が 落ち着いたんですからね
今は問題ないんだけど
ですから
答えというのは 自分で すぐ出す必要あるし
それは すぐ その場のことを
判断することから 生まれてくる
もう時間は消えちゃったんだけど
まだいっぱい
本番は まだ入ってないんです
智慧の現れる 本番は
それはただの
何て言いますか
舞台で 一番初めに 何と言いますか
あれはもう
前座だけなんです
まだ いっぱいあるんですけど
残念ながら 時間はないんです
次に 一つだけでも 言っておきますけど
物事の逆を考えてみましょう
みんなが 言ってる通りに
これだから こうなります
これだから こうなりますと 言うんだけど
そちらの 反対もあります
どんな 論理にも
どんな 考え方にも
その反対の考え方も あるんです
それも 考えておきましょう
いわゆる こういう論理です
すべての論は 反論を持っている
正っていうのは
負というものを 必ず持っています
そこを 両方 考えてほしい
例えば 子供って よく言うことを 聞いてくれると
よく 勉強するというのは ありがたいでしょう
それの逆はなんですか？
あの子供には 自分の独立性はない
自分で 考えることはできない
でしょ 言うとおりにするんだから
攻撃できない
そして いい子にしようと 自分を 責めなくちゃいけない
自分の 正直な気持ち
自分の精神的な いろいろ 葛藤とかね
表せない
それで ものすごく ひどい目に あっちゃうんです
大人になっちゃうと
それは 逆の論理なんです
やっぱり 子供だから 親の言うこと
大人の言うこと
先生の言うことを 聞きなさいと
それは 当たり前ではないか ということでもないんです
そちらの 反論も 考えてほしい
そこで じゃあ それだったら 子供はわがままで
自分の 気持ちを 表したい放題 表したりして
先生に 思う存分 反発したりして
すれば どうなるんですかと
そうすると きちんとした 独立性 でき上がるんではないかと
違うんです
そうすると 何も 勉強できない
わがままで
自分は そのままで 成長しない
なぜなら 自分の感情ばっかり 出したりするでしょう
そうすると 全然 成長しない
進化はなし
そのまんま
言うことを聞くと 変化は あるんだけど
個人は 死んじゃって
ただの ロボット
麻原のところで あの人々はね
勉強できる
頭 悪いんだけど
勉強できる人々が あれほど 悪いことをしたのは
いい子で 育てられたから なんです
自分で 考えられない
人を殺せ といえば
ああ そうですね
先生に言われるんだから
いい子は やるもんだと
おかしいと 自分で
考えるんじゃないんだ ということでしょう
そこで 論争するっていうのは
ただの 口で抑えることだと
あの上祐という バカが 思ってるんですね
その人だけじゃなくて
報道関係の人々も そう思ってるんです
口で むちゃくちゃ喋るのは
ものすごく論争が うまいんだと思ったら
みんな負けちゃったね
あんなくだらない
何の意味もない 言葉に 逆を考えないんです
ですから
どんな論にも 何が ありますか？
反論があります
そちら 両方考えると かなり自分も 元気であるし
いつでも違う智慧
論と反論の上にある
3番目の智慧が現れる
論は知識
反論も知識
論と反論を合わせたところで
何か違う方向
違うものが生まれてくる
それは 智慧なんです
これ結構 いい遊びなんです
反論を 考えるのは
私が いろんなものに 批判みたいなことを言うのは
いつでも 論と反論と 両方 考えているんだから
ですから
僕にとっては 何がいいかと いうことは
一つも言えないんです
政治 経済
社会 どんな問題についても
あなたの意見は 何ですかと
別に 意見があるわけじゃない
あなた方の意見を 言いなさいと
全部 片っ端から破っちゃいますよ
そちらの全部 反論は出せますけど
そこで じゃあどうすればいいかと聞けば
すぐ答えを出してあげる
これですと
いつでも 正論と反論
みんな 自分勝手だから
世の中の人間は 自分が思っているものを
正当化するために
正に するために 論理を成り立てるんですね 証拠は
でも 違う証拠や
壊す証拠も そこにあるんです
それは関係なしと
ですから
私たちは 智慧が 欲しいんだったら
正論 反論
両方考えて 考えて置いておく
そうすると
ちょっと 第3番目の答えが 出てくる
それに 智慧というんです
そこで 今日 ちょっと テキスト持ってきたんだけど
これで 智慧って何ですかって
仏教における 智慧を説明しようと
かなり 智慧があるんです
これ全部 1行ずつ  1行ずつ いろんな智慧の分析
だから ちょっとした 甘い話じゃないんです
智慧の世界 っていうのは
すごく 膨大なんです
仏教では 智慧の分析も きちんとあるんです
だいたい 名前だけでも
2 ページぐらいに わたりますけど
te-sattati ñāṇani
seventy-three
73種類あります
それは高度な智慧
仏教の世界で 言ってる
超越した智慧
その中で
sattasattati ñāṇāni sāvaka sādhāraṇāni
77種類の智慧が 釈尊の弟子たちに
得られることが できるんだと
いわゆる 悟らなきゃダメですけど
その場合は
77種類
そうすると 6残るんですね
6つ その6つは釈尊にだけあって
他の人には 得られないんだと
ですから
一般の人々には ちょっと得られない
ものすごい強力な 智慧もありますけど
でも 智慧としては 差が
73種類あるというんだけど
ただ すぐひらめく というところは 同じなんです
僕は これちょっと 目を通してみたんだけど
怖くて もう これから引用することは できないんです
あまりにも すごい世界です
この 反論から
最終的に これだけは 言わなくちゃいけないんだけど
これで話は 終わりますけど
反論から 我々に 正しい智慧が 生まれる
なぜかというと
この世の中では
人間は 欲で 自分勝手で
自分本位で
自分のために
好き勝手にものを言ったり 考えたりするだけ
ありのままのことを 言ってるわけじゃないんです
豚肉を 食べたいんだから
神様が作ってくれた と言うんですね
それには 理由が あるわけじゃないんです
ものすごい 勝手なんです
ユダヤ教では 海の魚を 食べてもいいと
空を飛ぶものは 食べてもいいと
鱗がはいっていて
スネがあるものは 食べてもいいと
それから いろいろ言って
でも 豚は 食べてはいけませんと
なぜならば
足が 牛と同じで
でも 体は なにか違うと
何か 訳を作ってるんですね
ただ 豚肉が 嫌いだったでしょうね
もしかすると
そこで 誰も ヒンドゥー教だったら 牛は 食べないんですね
インドの文化は 農業社会だから
牛は 仕事するんですね
それも 食べるようになっちゃったら
もう 全部台無し なんですね
ですから
食べない気持ちは わかりますけど
ずっと 仕事をしてくれる 牛をね
殺して 食べるということは
やっぱり できるもんじゃないしね
その代わりに 豚は かわいそうに
チキン ニワトリは かわいそうですね
ユダヤ教にしても
イスラム教にしても
やっぱり 豚は食べない と置いておくし
鶏は 食べるし
僕は それでそれに 面白く言うのは
牛 食べてはいけないと ある人々は 言う
豚肉食べたら 汚れると ある人々は言うし
誰も 鶏には 親切じゃないんではないか
じゃあ 私は 新しい宗教を作ろう
鶏 食うなと
誰か 鶏を 助けてあげなくちゃ いけないんだから
人間の論理っていうのは ものすごく いい加減なんですね 結局は
日本人は すごく酒が 好きなんですね
だから 仏教で 酒飲むなと言うんだけど
よく言うんですね
と言っても
あーだ こうだとか
それはと言っても
別に 知識があるわけでもないし
酒は 体に悪いっていうことを 自分でも知ってるはずでしょうし
ただ 飲みたいっていうことだけ なんですね
それを 正直に認めないで
それに 哲学を言う
だから 僕は怒るんですね
私は 酒飲みたい なんて言ったら
僕は その人に 全然 微かにも 怒らないんです
正直だから
飲みたいよと
それに と言っても
酒は 適量に体にとると 健康的になるんではないかとか
食べ物が 美味しくなるんじゃないかとか
神様に それは ちゃんと お供えしてるんじゃないかとか
日本の伝統ではないかとか
結婚式でも 酒飲むじゃないかとかね
だから みんな 結婚 むちゃくちゃですから
酒飲んで かわしちゃってます 盃
正気じゃないんだからね
それより 牛乳とかね
水とか 飲んだ方が いいかもしれませんけど
そういうふうに
もう いろんなことを 言えるでしょう
面白いよ
そんなことを言うと
普通だったら なんかね
お酒を こうやって入れて
それを三回飲んで
また あの人も ついで すごいことで
あれ 酔っ払っちゃうんだから
あなた方 正気じゃないんだから
結婚できるわけないよ とも言えるし
水を飲めと
水は 清らかで 基本的で
命の元であって
とにかくまあ
そういうなんとかね
理由を言って 酒飲みたいと 理由をつける
だから そこで 正直なところは
私は 飲みたい
いくら 釈尊が やめなさいと言っても
なんか 私は やっぱり それでも やりたいという
正直なところは 言わない
ですから
世の中の 論理っていうのは そんなもんで
全然 怖いものはないんです
ですから すぐ
そういう 反論の立場
この 違う方向も 見ていくと
結論として これを 言える
すべての 生命は 永遠に生きたいと
死にたくはないんだと
生きていて よかったとか
人生は 幸福だと
尊い命だと
我々には ありがたい霊魂
魂 仏心などが 付いているんだ とか言ってるでしょう
宗教の世界や いろんなところで
それは 全部嘘です
証拠はないでしょう
あれ ただ執着
自分の希望
ごまかしてるだけ
ですから
智慧が現れたら 悟るっていうのは そういうことなんです
全てが わかってくるんです
他の宗教を 片っ端から 勉強しなくても
何 言ってるかと
だいたい ヨーロッパ型のね 外国型の宗教
どんな 宗教見ても
永遠の命 というのを 約束しているんですね
天国で それは 人間の希望ですね
それは 死にたくないんだから
現れることなんですね
死にたくないんですけど
死ぬでしょ
おかしいのは 確実に死ぬのに
それを 認めたくないという
完全に 馬鹿 馬鹿しい
完全に 完璧に 確実に 死ぬでしょ
それを 認めたくないが故に
巨大な文明 文化 宗教 哲学 作ってるんだから
全部 倒れちゃうんです
ちょっと 1本の柱の上に すごい建物を 作ってるんです
事実を見るということで
その全部
この 空の上に建ってる 建物は 壊れるんです
ですから
お釈迦様は 生きてるものは みんな 死にますと
すべては 無常ですと
物には 実体とか 変化しないものは 何もないんだと
瞬間 瞬間 変わっていくんだと
これは 私のものだというふうな 取るものは何もないし
これは 私というものは 何もないと
人間 絶対に認めたくないことを 言ってるんです
でも それは 残念ながら 事実なんです
ですから
今 幻覚の 嘘の世界
人々が 認めたい嘘の中にいて
そうすると 反論を 見てみると
真実の 世界は 見つかるんです
ですから
智慧の 最高なところ っていうのは
無常を 知ることで
無常を 体験すること なんです
苦しみ dukkhaを 体験することなんです
それは すごく 超越したレベルなんです
その瞬間に 全てを わかって
全ての物事を理解して
全てに対する 執着を 捨てて 解脱っていうものを 体験する
ですから
この方法でいけば
普通の生き方も 楽しくなっちゃうし
ストレスは 消えちゃうし
健康的になるし
智慧が どんどん発展していって
解脱も 体験することができます
ということで 終了します
ありがとうございます